yeah well you guys are normies this is
why in high school I had this friend
named Brady he was he could he was so
strong he can pull he could pull a stop
sign out of the ground okay inhuman
strength wasn't it no he wasn't he was
cousins I want to get it I don't get in
trouble but so one day there's this guy
named Todd he was an older guy maybe in
his early 20s and he was a weed dealer
so Brady I go Brady he was kind of like
this big kind of dumb what kind of a guy
how long and I was a little guy yeah and
I was a little guy and I could tell him
what to do I see myself as money I go
Brady
open the window to Todd's house I will
steal his weed so he broke this window
all right they broke it I snuck into the
little space I stole his weed and then
what we did was we put in my car hid in
my car and we waited Todd to get home
and when he got home we rang his
doorbell and he goes like okay can we
buy some weed he goes someone broke into
our house my house and stole the weed
and we could and we helped him look
forward to god oh my god you're one of
those we help him look a real good dad
right and so from ours him and I we went
down the streets we know we have I'm one
of those drug addicts you know that
there's that one kid who easily yeah you
know how you know who the suspect is
it's like that one kid who had murdered
that little girl and hid her inside his
water bed and when the whole need that's
right on a search he was the first one
to volunteer because I'll help you I'll
be his flashlight and everything I'll
help you and in the meantime the girl
was based like in his water bag yeah
inside his water bag did you guys hear
these stories torn skill I can't listen
to those and then what happened why why
they're gnarly yeah they're yeah and
then what happened was um his mom a week
later was walking through his room
trying to clean out whatever
and she see he sees it like there's some
fluid coming from like underneath his
water bed hmm she goes what is that the
water but pumping but it's darkness
fluid mm-hmm and she she puts her hand
on it it's red and she looks in
underneath the relevant and there's a
dead carcass of this little drill that's
been missing right and now as a mother
she sat there for like a good five
minutes going what do I do and then she
walked on the street and went to a cop
and said my my I found her
imagine that and and but check this out
I don't know why you brought this up but
check this out so he was 14 and he got a
life without parole could then later
later there was a new I think the
Supreme Court said it's unethical for a
child to get life in prison if they
commit a crime even as heinous as that
at the age of 14 so all these kids are
across the country right they got their
like cases overturned except he was the
only one that didn't good because his
case was so gruesome because he kept
killed he he killed her and then would
leave I like put him at her underneath
the thing at the bed and she could hear
her coughing so he would pull her back
out and kill her again like he did sit
and she was like 9 I just didn't want to
get into it anyway yeah sort of skillet
keeps me I had it I was sleep I was
listening to sort in scale to go to bed
the worst one the most people's face why
not you know I need something to listen
to to go to bed and I listened to it and
it would be like 11:00 a.m. and I'm am I
on my fifth one Ben do it the one with
the leaves
yeah one for me to hear was when that
father he had parasomnia so when I her
saw me so while he was while he was
sleepwalking he basically murdered all
his kids no he tried to kill his kids
but he only killed one no you killed two
no he killed one youngest one yeah
youngest one but he yeah he tried to
strangle all of his kids he killed one
and oh me too yes yes leap the prize for
a long time and I want he listened to it
on there on the the car ride to Arizona
yeah you're like captivated yeah we
didn't like pull off to this truck stops
we were like no no keep but even his
testimony was heartbreaking cuz you know
he loved his family
there was just he had been
sleep-deprived for so long that it there
ate something crossed over between
reality and dream and he ended up like
basically hurting his so they released
him yeah but I you know I actually
believe him and they're like I saw this
show on was it like Discovery Health or
something like that where this woman she
during sleepwalking she would go cheat
on her partner and have full-blown sex
with other people and those from bad
skill - no no I'm gonna see something
controversial okay is let me just throw
out this idea even if it was he was in
sleepwalking mode right sleep mode and
he he killed his kid and regardless if
he had control over his he did do it
action right so he wasn't aware of it he
wasn't it doesn't matter he did it his
conscious intent wasn't there still did
it though he wasn't conscious so was not
alive because of him yeah I realize that
you know and if your [ __ ] girl
cheating on your husband
cuz you're on sleep mode right right
it's like each
but that's not something she can help
welcome so what is a husband - alright
well you know next time you're on sleep
mode but if you ever happy forever off
sleep mode then we're in trouble
[Music]